[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we're glad you're here
we had a diplomatic incident last month
and a lot of americans didn't even know
what happened the government of france
did something they haven't done in
hundreds of years they recalled their
ambassador to the united states they
also accused the united states of
behaving in a manner that is quote
unacceptable between allies and partners
no it wasn't a cheese embargo that made
the french mad they were angry that the
bib administration agreed to provide
nuclear power submarines to australia
france had wanted to sell its own
submarines and the buy administration
effectively killed that deal it hurt
france and they were mad about it
now we haven't had a problem with france
this profound since to be specific 1798
john adams was president then and the
interesting thing is he had no idea that
we had a problem with france it took
months for words to reach him back in
washington that american and french
diplomats were fighting with one another
by the time adams learned about this
diplomatic dispute which became known as
the xyz affair it was too late to stop
it a naval war mostly fought in the
caribbean broke out between the united
states and france
so the lesson from that conflict was
pretty simple if you're going to run the
united states you have to be pretty
aware of what the rest of the world is
doing particularly major world powers
particularly your allies
so with that in mind john kerry the
former secretary of state now our
climate czar was asked what happened
here
and his response was really simple
like john adams joe biden had no idea
that the french were upset now unlike
john adams
our current president has the benefit of
cell phones and the internet
but he still didn't know
joe biden didn't know because he's in
mental decline there are a lot of things
he doesn't know including when our
allies are furious with us and start
withdrawing their ambassadors
so kerry was asked to explain all this
by a french news channel
why did the buy administration cut
france out of a nuclear submarine deal
with australia and his response was
amazing he said joe biden did this
because joe biden was completely unaware
there was a problem in the first place
watch this
and president biden asked me about it
and i told him and expressed
you told joe biden that he was not the
right he asked me he said what's the
situation and i explained exactly
he was he had not been aware of that he
literally literally had not been aware
of what had transpired
was the last time you heard
someone from the us government admit the
president was completely clueless he
literally had not been aware of what had
transpired now you're probably not
shocked by that joe biden was visibly
confused throughout the entire
presidential campaign here's one example
good evening
thanks so much for tuning in no man has
a right to raise a hand to a woman in
anger other than in self-defense and
that's rarely ever occurs and so we have
to just change the culture period and
keep punching at it and punching at it
and punching it play the radio make sure
the television excuse me make sure you
have the record player on at night four
kids are just as bright and just as tall
as white kids we choose science over
fiction we choose truth over facts
and we're not trying to be mean as we've
said many times we feel sorry for joe
biden all of us hope to live to the age
we face those kinds of problems and the
truth is voters knew
what they were getting when they voted
for joe biden what's interesting is that
now that he's in office biden's handlers
are doing everything they can to prevent
us from noticing that he's not really in
charge
take a look at the latest example these
are pictures of a fake white house set
that the buy administration has for some
reason constructed across the street
from the actual white house it's in an
auditorium at the eisenhower executive
office building why go to the trouble
they already have a white house
well stephen miller spent the last four
years in the white house as an advisor
to trump and here's his explanation for
it because he would know quote the
reason biden uses this bizarre virtual
set for televised meetings is not an
actual room like the east room the
cabinet the oval the roosevelt sit room
etc a lot of rooms the reason he does
this is because it allows him to read a
script directly from a face on monitor
and without teleprompter glass that can
be seen on camera
oh
now we can't verify that that's true but
it certainly sounds right
joe biden can't speak from the oval
office because he's not sure what to say
so he has to read it all here
so that raises a much deeper question
the question is not is joe biden
mentally impaired obviously he is and
again we're not going to gloat over it
but a much more important question for
the rest of us is if he's not running
the government
then who is
that's a real question
clearly the fbi the doj and the military
are already acting independently of the
elected president of the united states
as you just saw they don't even keep
them informed of international incidents
instead
they are in some cases freelancing to
crush anyone who opposes their power
mike flynn for example he was briefly
the national security advisor in the
trump administration what we learned
from the destruction of mike flynn
really
was that sure you can elect donald trump
president but does he really run the
executive branch of government no it
turned out barack obama was still in
charge even though he was no longer
president
so obama had his cronies charged mike
flynn with a crime talking to russia as
the national security adviser which of
course is not a crime by any stretch
and they wrecked his life for doing that
it took years for us this is how slow we
are to figure out exactly what had
happened there but now it's very obvious
we just sat down with a long interview
with mike flynn it's coming out monday
and he told us what is really obvious to
everyone who watches
an unelected group within washington
effectively runs the country without
reference to voters here's his
assessment
we have two separate governments we have
the one that actually gets elected and
goes into office
and then you have a government
inside of washington dc that operates
under no rules uh no authorities other
than their own or who's ever in charge
of their sounds like that government was
still controlled by barack obama yeah
and and i would say that that's that uh
to a degree is is what we're operating
with today
by the way mike flynn is not some
internet celebrity or conservative
activist he was a three-star general he
was the head of an intelligence agency
he was the number two guy for all
american intelligence he spent his
entire life working in the federal
government and succeeding at that so he
knows what he's talking about he is a
reliable guide to how the government
actually works
our whole conversation with mike flynn
by the way is on tucker carlson today
it's coming out monday on fox nation but
it's not just mike flynn who's being
destroyed
every ideological opponent of the regime
is under attack parents in school board
meetings saying unapproved things
yesterday joe biden's flak refused to
rule out using the patriot act to hunt
down american parents who are upset
about what their kids are learning watch
this
would the administration be okay
with the fbi using the patriot act to
surveil these parents if that is what
they decide i don't speak on behalf of
the national school board association i
speak on behalf of this government the
attorney general has can put out a
letter they will take actions they take
and i would point to them for more
information
oh so this is the spokesman for the
president united states saying of the
justice department they're going to take
actions that they're going to take like
we don't really have any control over
this and she may be on to something
there it does increasingly seem like the
national security state runs everything
you remember the doj recently dispatched
its anti-terrorism national security
division to investigate ordinary parents
calling them domestic terrorists the doj
is also developing training sessions to
tell school board members that free
speech is actually violence
so who's really in charge
it's a really interesting question hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else